nordkoreas diktator kim jong un ist als
krisenmanager unterwegs besucht eine
apotheke die die staatliche propaganda
wohl extra für seinen auftritt
hergerichtet hat und selbst das reicht
dem großen führer nicht die apotheken
seien unzureichend für den virus
ausgestattet kritisiert er die straßen
der hauptstadt pjöngjang sind
menschenleer die vielen desinfektions
teams können nicht darüber
hinwegtäuschen dass nordkorea schlecht
auf den ausbruch vorbereitet ist
impfstoffe aus dem ausland hat das
abgeschottete land abgelehnt die
ratschläge im staatlichen fernsehen
wirken fast hilflos
schlafen sie genug trinken sie genug
essen sie leicht verdauliches und spülen
sie den mund mit salzwasser aus
das virus trifft auf ein bitterarmes und
ungeimpften land den meisten geht es bei
weitem nicht so gut wie der
vorzeigefamilie mit ihrem vorzeige
optimismus
ich bin zuversichtlich dass wir mit der
richtigen medizin das virus besiegen
können
kim jong-un muss sich entscheiden ohne
hilfe vom ausland versinkt sein land
wohl im corona chaos
über die korona situation in nordkorea
spreche jetzt mit unserem
korrespondenten für die region ulf
röller schönen guten tag die un hat ja
extra ein beschaffungs system aufgelegt
um über kovacs das ist eine initiative
die einen weltweit gleich mit
gleichmäßigen zugang zu coop 19
impfstoffen gewährleisten will um
impfdosen eben auch in ärmere länder zu
geben warum hat sich bisher nicht auf
das programm eingelassen
also offiziell wurde das immer von
nordkorea begründet mit dem argument
dass man das nicht braucht dass man
alleine klar kommt man kann also sagen
da schwingt stolz mit auch eine gewisse
macht arroganz des diktators kim jong il
und nun ist eben das passiert was nicht
passieren durfte ist dürfte es gibt
diesen angekommen ausbruch
wahrscheinlich hatte man ja zu beginn
der korona krise vor zwei jahren das
komplett abgeschottet um gehofft dass so
das virus nicht reinkommt nur das hat
die sowieso schon schwierige
wirtschaftslage des landes noch mal
dramatisch verschlechtert weil die
wenigen waren die normalerweise aus
china nach nordkorea kommen neben nicht
mehr gekommen sind und dann musste man
irgendwann doch die grenzen aufmachen um
ein paar nahrungsmittel und waren rein
kommen zu lassen und so gehen viele
experten davon aus dass so das virus
auch nach nordkorea gekommen ist und nun
ist die katastrophe da es ist ein land
das sehr sehr armes wo viele viele
menschen unterernährt sind und eben
nicht geimpft und jetzt gibt es eben
diesen vielleicht hilferuf vom diktator
kim jong un war der hat doch etwas sehr
erstaunliches gemacht er hat die
führungseliten des landes heftig
kritisiert er hat von versagen
gesprochen da will er einerseits von
seinem eigenen versagen ablenken und
andererseits ist es vielleicht doch
jetzt ein zeichen dass nordkorea
bereitet hilfe vom ausland anzunehmen
und sage ich mal sein nationalstolz
runterzuschlucken wie wird dieser
offensichtliche cupid ausbruch in
nordkorea in der region wahrgenommen
oh
ja der wird sehr vage man muss ja wissen
dass nordkorea ein landes das die ganze
region nervös macht sowohl die
bündnispartner china als auch eben die
die angst vor nordkorea haben südkorea
und japan es ist ja ein land und es hat
es auch weiter gemacht auch in der krise
jetzt das ständig raketentests macht und
sein atomprogramm
atomwaffenprogramm weiter ausbaut und
deswegen beobachtet man sehr genau wenn
dieses land immer unstabiler unsicherer
wird wenn vielleicht auch der diktator
kim schon unter druck kommt dann ist oft
der fall dass er weitere raketentests
macht und das will natürlich jeder
vermeiden deswegen hat das nachbarland
südkorea als erstes soforthilfe
angeboten hat gesagt wir sind bereit zu
liefern medikamente und auch impfstoffe
zu liefern wie gesagt bisher gibt es
noch kein signal von nordkorea dass es
diese hilfe annimmt
man muss sich eben entscheiden wenn er
wirklich bei der politik der isolierung
bleibt wird es eine große große
mit katastrophe in dem land geben und
das wäre für die ganze region gefährlich
sagt unser korrespondent für die region
ulf röller vielen dank für das gespräch